bonjour cette semaine c'est un énorme
coup de coeur dont je voudrais vous
faire part
il s'agit de plans ses plans c'est ce
n'est pas vraiment un film c'est une
création de la compagnie déclic théâtre
troupe d'improvisation qui est un
attrape est donc cette année nous avons
choisi de travailler ensemble sur le
thème du cinéma et leur spectacle de
2017 leurs créations ça s'appelle plan c
c'est un spectacle d'improvisation sur
le thème du cinéma
et ils vont venir
avec leur équipe sur la scène du grenier
à sel et on vous a préparé quelques
surprises pour vous mettre dans
l'ambiance des films et la création des
films des clips et à 2 va créer des
films en direct avec vous et
vous allez les aider lors donné des
consignes on a besoin de vous public
donc ce sera le samedi 25 février à
20h45
il y à deux tarifs le plein tarif c'est
6 euros mais si vous avez une carte
bande dessinée si vous avez une carte
grain de sel si vous êtes adhérent à
déclic ces trois euros il faut réserver
parce qu'il ya déjà plus beaucoup de
place c'est il faut réserver sur le site
www.declicfrance.com et vous retrouvez
aussi toutes les informations sur notre
site internet cinéma grenier à sel
points comme si vous voulez en savoir
plus
à bientôt